voters in South Carolina head to the
polls this Saturday for the state's
critical primary the Democratic
candidates have been buying for the
black vote which is expected to make up
about 60% of the electorate in that
contest president Trump's campaign
announced yesterday they are opening
fifteen so-called black voices for trump
offices around the country to woo black
voters the president will have a rally
there tomorrow in South Carolina our
national correspondent Jericka Duncan
spoke to some of the voters there
Jericka good morning to you what did
they tell you well we know that
President Trump has emphasized for the
last few years that he has done a lot
for people in the black community often
citing the lowest unemployment numbers
for african-americans ever so we
traveled to South Carolina to better
understand what some black voters there
are feeling african-american communities
has suffered under Democratic control to
those I say the following what do you
have to lose president Trump's plea to
african-american voters began in the
summer of 2016 and it has grown even
stronger as we approach Election Day I
have been working to build an unlimited
future for african-american communities
Robert Baker who works as a corporate
trainer in the mortgage industry agrees
we have force or the lowest
african-american unemployment in history
when I saw the economy get better I
noticed my four on one case first thing
I said 401k begins to grow the stock
market is growing Tonia Isaac says she's
having a different experience she works
part-time as a home health care aide and
is on public assistance you have in this
cycle of when you get this good job then
your rent goes up doing your food stamps
that could be your child carries could
Adolphus Bell Jr is a professor of
political science and african-american
studies at Winthrop University in South
Carolina the gap between white and black
homeowners is greater now than it was
since before the Fair Housing Act of
1968 when segregation was legal what
does that say when you look at
the big picture of the economy as it
relates to black people it's one of the
reasons why we have to examine multiple
indicators and socio-economic well-being
to get a sense of where people really
are a recent poll found 84 percent of
black voters disapprove of president
Trump's job in office and according to a
January Washington Post Epps's poll 83
percent of black Americans believe the
president is a racist you believe the
president has made racist remarks but
you do not believe he is a race car why
people hockey ain't racist the way that
he talks the way the things that he has
said has pushed people to the point they
feel that they can just say and do
whatever they want without any
repercussions do you think the
president's racist yes and while Tonya
and Robert disagree on who should be
President
both say they're concerned about the
obvious deep divisions that exist you
said something interesting about what
your 13 year old daughters sent to you
yeah
what did she saying that was so
concerning so we were upstairs talking
in the bedroom I'm letting her know CBS
is coming dinner need your dad
african-american trump supporter mm-hmm
and she says that is somebody gonna want
to kill you it's it's we're in a bad
place when you hear a young girl
concerned about her father because he's
expressing how he feels politically what
do you think about that it shouldn't be
she shouldn't have to worry but the sad
truth is is because of our president it
is a divide 8% of black voters voted for
President Trump in 2016 according to a
CBS News exit poll Robert Baker who you
heard from was not one of them he
actually called himself a never ever
Trump or who voted for a third party
candidate Baker says he changed his mind
when he saw the positive impact that
Trump had on the economy he's doing well
economically stories earlier this
morning it's not it's not extending to
everybody and it's not just that one or
two things to look at and that's what
Professor Belk was explaining when you
look at homeownership when you look at
wealth disparity there's still a lot of
things that you can't say
everybody's doing much better and he
highlighted that obviously in the piece
but it will be interesting because you
have more african-american men that also
support Trump and fewer african-american
women so there's always you always have
to go beneath the headline I think very
troubling what his daughter was worried
about her father because the children
are listening and they are walking and
what they're thinking you know based on
what they see out there in the ether it
matters it does number that 84 percent
disapproval rating among
african-americans is pretty imposing for
the president disapprove will think he's
a racist though that's 83 per second
that you